john welcome to the podcast
pleasure to be here
really excited for this this is a sort
of another
installment of
uh sitting down with uh people
recruiters that have sort of gone on a
journey over the last however sort of
many years or months on taking their
career taking their skill set to
the american market so
really excited to sort of dive into the
last two years where you've gone on that
journey but where we always like to
start is uh the million pound question
so i'd love to hear your take on what
you believe are the common
characteristics and traits of a modern
day successful recruiter in your opinion
cool um so
i think there's loads of traits that
make a good recruiter everyone is
obviously always different
one of the big things that i like to
pick up on with this is i don't believe
that there's any difference in actual
extroverts or introverts in in
recruitment i think you can make it work
with your skill set
it's um i see curiosity as is a real
trait that i look for in people the
drive to understand everything about
everyone and just being inquisitive
about what's what's going on what's out
there i really like to see people that
are excited um about what the future
holds and and how they can get to it
um people that are driven and and that
can be like an innate drive a
competitive drive a reason to to do this
hard job
outside of of just coming here for the
money
and people that are a hell of a
networker and that's huge in the market
that i'm in but i see it everywhere
being able to network and talk to people
it's not innate in everyone but it can
definitely be trained and learned
um and then finally people with an
entrepreneurial spirit which we'll
probably touch on later on
yeah i like it's definitely something
that's come up more and more but i would
just really quickly love to
i i love the curious piece
i would say i'm someone that's really
curious and that's something i looked
for when i hired for my business just
because i feel like if you're someone
that is curious
i don't know there's just so many good
things that come with that
so like i guess what i wanted to ask you
is is that something that
mainly comes with like the sort of
natural curiosity or is it something
that you think can be cultivated
i definitely think it can be cultivated
i'm a big believer and a lot of the
traits that are good for a recruitment
consultant can be trained can be learned
curiosity for me is just having that
self-awareness to to want to understand
more and also curiosity as well is about
self-development and and trying to dig
into what can make things tick
um i think it's so important
no yeah no agreed
so obviously we're gonna sort of spend
the next 40 45 minutes talking about and
unpacking
this journey that you've been on which
you started in july 2020 right right and
um obviously before that like you've
obviously worked in recruitment for
coming up to a decade so obviously eight
years so obviously prior to that had
obviously um obviously you've been
working for for vantage uh and you've
been there for a year as i said eight
years for the first six obviously
focused on the uk markets
and then obviously from july 2020
you've been uh heading up and sort of
focused on the the usps particularly
sort of east coast so i guess
obviously we're going to unpack this but
just to sort of
paint a picture of where you are today
what i've got down and sort of let me
know if i'm missing anything but when we
prepared for this so it's been the last
two years
you're now going to be sort of a team of
seven people
um and it's all permanent uh business
that you've been doing and as i said
yeah you've focused on the east coast
uh of the us
yeah that's that's absolutely right and
then what what markets have you focused
on from the uk like you were doing sort
of tech and engineering or different
parts of that what sort of markets and
niches have you focused on the six years
i've been in recruitment have have all
been around engineering so that's that's
what we sort of started the business
with
mostly focused around kind of
automation process within life sciences
okay cool and then that's that's the
case in the east coast as well in the us
absolutely yeah we're this quarter we've
now expanded into sort of tech
um moving into um into different areas
of the business but our core has has
been engineering and that that's my
previous experience
okay cool and just so just so i
understand that because the engineering
is broad like i just want to understand
so like engineering in life sciences
yeah correct like white collar um the
guys that program the machinery that
that makes the drugs
right okay yeah i just wanted to make
sure i understand understand that
because that help helps me in this
conversation uh okay cool so
when did when did sort of
thinking about going to america thinking
about doing business in america getting
your radar where does this sort of
initial where did this come from
that's been a long time in the making
honestly um we've been talking about the
us as a business for for quite some time
up until very recently i had two sisters
that lived there one in philadelphia one
in north carolina um so
in the background that has probably been
maybe four four years
um but it was
really coming into sort of
the planning stages we we started
nailing down like ideal client types
candidate types locations um and then
during covered
um i had the opportunity to to put my
hand up and say yeah i want to go and
lead this out in the u.s
okay
obviously u.s is huge
as we said east coast
what like how did you
obviously i'm assuming like this would
be part of your research and market
mapping and understanding of life
sciences in your sector but
like what
how did you sort of go about identifying
states that you wanted to focus on or
did you even decide to focus on states
in the first place
so i took it out to boston um initially
so in massachusetts um huge pharma life
sciences hub
um
off the back of that there are some
other great hubs in um in the east coast
that we've started to to develop out now
but
boston's got some some really solid
investment i'm huge by tech
companies and an investment in the area
so that that was where we started
that's where you started okay cool
so talk to me a bit about then and
if it wasn't like entirely concrete then
you can be honest
but like what was the go-to-market
strategy like how how do you think about
no one is going to have a [ __ ] clue
who john is
i'm calling from where you're based in
stafford right yeah staffordshire yeah
so like john calling from staffordshire
going into boston huge market like what
was it what was the strategy here like
the first 90 days what did that look
like what was the plan for the first 90
days
cool so as i say like the bigger picture
of the go to market was to roll out the
success that we've had over the last
decade
vantage uk take out to the us and europe
the go to market for for the us was to
build our engineering business initially
it's my background i'd like to think i
know it well
and
as we started in the middle of covid um
a lot of the engineering businesses and
the types of companies i would typically
recruit for in engineering contracts in
the uk most of the staff was furloughed
or business just wasn't quite there so
we
pivoted that into the life sciences
sector and it's been really successful
for us
a lot of the work initially is like
as i call it donkey work so you're
developing your client profiles your
candidate profiles
um working out the us sort of
contractual side of the business making
sure you've got the right contacts
within industry
and then it was sort of developing that
database
growing out who needs to be on there
because this was from scratch completely
cold
so
it was networking around
the ideal candidate profiles initially
building groups of like-minded engineers
within communities and engaging with
with those guys
and girls um finding out the real pain
points within the industry talking to
those in more senior capacities but
still within the same niche
and starting to to develop out from
there to really understand what was
going on in the boston sort of biotech
engineering sector
and that allowed me to to take it to
market with
the hiring managers and senior
stakeholders that were aligned with with
what we were going after
okay so yeah so basically what i took
from that then is
you did you did this smart thing by just
taking a bit of a step and i'm sure it
can evolve right and you like definitely
just continue to learn really what is
the ideal customer profile ideal
candidate profile but to start you
thought about that in terms of yeah the
types of people you want to be speaking
to the types of companies that you can
help
so you did that understood that and then
what i got from that then is you just
really double down on speaking to people
building relationships being curious
back to that finding out what yeah what
are the sort of nuances and challenges
of of being in that working in that
sector in boston could you would you
mind just sharing with us like under i
understand that but like what
what did you lead with and what what did
those actual first conversations
actually look like do you know what i
mean were they happening on linkedin
like was it quite easy to get on the
phone to people and then like what is it
that you led with was it like hey look
john um i am new to the boston area um
this is what i'm looking to do this is
our sort of grand division these are
some of the things that i'm hoping that
you might be able to help me with i'd
love to speak like what do those initial
conversations look like yeah exactly
that it was it was mostly networking
conversations around hey look this is
why i'm credible i've been doing this
for six years in the uk and europe i
have built some relationships with
pharma companies in in the eu
i understand what you do at a granular
level
i just don't know the market so well i
was open with it like i'm coming to
market i'm coming to help you guys
but
it was more so about the networking like
what can i do to support you how can i
help you find your next position et
cetera et cetera
yeah okay and people people quite
receptive to that yeah fine um so you
asked about linkedin
conversations start on linkedin
typically but you need to move them to
the phone um that's where the
relationship is built
you engage initially on linkedin and you
move it forward quickly
and like what
how like again what what did that what
did why would they get on the phone with
you like what was you saying was like
i'd love it'd be great if we could
network i'm looking to build my net like
why would they if you didn't have a job
or anything
why they give you time culturally like
when we're engaging with people in the
us they are a lot more open from from my
experience to just having networking
conversations if you're in the space and
they view your profile you look like a
credible person
they're open to having that conversation
even if it's not for an immediate need
that's certainly what i found in the
early days obviously now we can talk
about vacancies we can talk about
retained assignments and things like
that but yeah absolutely it was it was
open with being a networking
conversation and and this is what i'm
doing this is what i'm trying to achieve
now i think the sort of thing that i'm
picking up on is you
you called these networking
conversations i quite like that
so
okay so two things on this because i
think this will be useful for people one
what did a successful networking call
look like
like when you got off that coin and go
really happy with that call like what
because do you know what i mean
obviously the best recruiters aren't
transactional right that like you're
playing short medium term long term game
here so i'm sure there's things that
you're thinking like what information
can i get from this person which means i
can then start trying to speak to some
companies that might be hiring right
like what yeah what did a successful
networking call look like what sort of
things were you aiming to try and get
from those calls
sure so i mean look my background is
contract engineering uk midlands so very
much about
where are the leads who's hiring who's
agreeing what what can i find out about
this market so i can build it
but also i might take some information
from the candidate i spoke with the
conversation before about a new facility
being opened in
austin or something that's being
mothballed and sort of investment in the
area
it's as important to to try and engage
in conversation with bits of information
that you can find from
newsletters and e-signs and industry
information boards and take it to market
and just engage in that conversation but
a successful call would a be that they'd
pick up the call to me again um and we'd
have that conversation at the end if if
i had something that that would fit for
them
will you speak to me um but yeah if if
there was a lead if there was any bit of
information that i could use to forward
my to take my business forward
absolutely that that would be a great
call for me
yeah no thanks for sharing that and then
the the other thing because i i feel
like people listen to this or think it
depending on where they're on their
journey and i'm sure this is something
you've now helped your growing team with
obviously you had
the added benefit of like you said going
to market and going hey i've done this
successfully in the uk eu this is my
track record i'm now taking that to the
us
what what's your advice for people at
this beginning stage who don't have that
track record like what what what do you
lead with what sort of thing is it still
like a networking call and growing my
network this is what we're trying to
achieve in the us
because i i can't call you john and say
or lead with i've got this track record
which is why i'm credible and i'm sure
you've had to help your team with this
yeah absolutely so
a lot we do a lot of work with with the
new members of the team around their
market mapping like the first couple of
weeks is understanding who who are the
players who's out there what information
can you find from as i say newsletters
designs etc
um
if you can utilize that effectively you
can demonstrate credibility quite
quickly i mean
if you've got
previous um reviews and recommendations
on your linkedin i actively utilize them
so to my team even if it's not directly
relevant it shows that you're a
recruiter that's worth their salt
okay interesting
so
i guess the first thing i'd love to just
hear your thoughts on then so you've
told us a bit about the initial strategy
and how how long did it sort of take you
to build traction do you think or how
long did it take to do your first us
placement
uh 21 days was was nice
21 days so how long did it take to sign
your first client
um within 14
really
yeah
what did you plan for what did you plan
for like two and a half months
two and a half months yeah
that's amazing yeah man
yeah that is like well i do that is one
of the crazy things about recruitment
isn't it where it's like you've done
you've obviously did the pre legwork
like you said donkey whatever you want
to call it but then you went from like
john has never done the us market to 14
days signing terms and so on the
contract
that's pretty cool
yeah mate i couldn't believe it honestly
wild
yeah yeah that's crazy so
i guess what um
what what i wanted to ask you was what
did you
what did you find quite early on maybe
didn't work that maybe worked in the uk
market compared to the us market out of
interest if there isn't a thing yeah
absolutely so
again going back to the engineering
contract days you'd pull up a list of
how managers that you know are in your
patch and you'd work through them
do 20 calls in a day
not comfortably but you'd get there
in the us
calling through a list of numbers just
isn't anywhere near as effective
as as i found it in the uk you
absolutely can do it and it's an
important part of building relationships
and
engaging with people it's certainly
something we still do
but the conversations that you've
pre-arranged the the ones that you've
sort of got a team's meeting in the
diary or you you've put something in
their calendar they're worth so much
more the substance and and the
conversation that you get out of those
calls is is way better so that was a
huge change for me
um another difference that i found i've
i've yet to find a job board that is
worthwhile in the us
linkedin recruiter um i was so used to
going on job site and monster and resume
library like you get a contract vacancy
and you can fill it with the first
couple of cvs if if you're quick enough
and you do the right things but
that just doesn't happen in the us um
certainly not my experience
okay thanks for sharing that so
interesting so what on on the client
piece then like what what did you find
obviously you shared a few things and it
might be some of the things you've
already shared but obviously you're on
you've been on this journey of the last
two years now what what has been the
sort of most effective and consistent
way
of
having conversations and signing
contracts with that ideal customer
profile do you think what's ended up
being and there may not be one
particular way but what's ended up being
the sort of
yeah overall best way
um
and i know it's it's quite easy for me
to say with with years of experience but
demonstration of credibility so
um
utilizing capability statements
recommendations referrals if you do a
really good job for your clients in in
the us talking to them about internal
and extra external referrals
that's being led to some really great
client wins one thing that i really
focus myself and the team on is building
around the the vacancies that we have so
i went to market i pulled the job
i filled it i took the candidates that
were there
and i found the ideal clients for those
candidates and built around that and
that's essentially how
the initial market we built snowballed
so basically what you're saying there
sorry is making sure that
you're basically the the vacancies that
you are working on
um your obviously the candidates that
you're working with you're then gonna
the people that you source and spend
time building relationships with
aren't just gonna be for that one
vacancy they'll be for the other types
of vacancies at your pool they're going
to be similar is that what you're saying
sorry yeah
so niche haven't had she's
focused in really tight candidate short
markets that the candidates that we
find the people that we're speaking with
we want to be able to talk to them about
three four five vacancies so that we're
confident that the candidates that that
we've got in the pipeline are ultimately
going to be people that that we go and
help secure a new role
okay yeah no that's interesting
so with when it comes to the the
contract piece with
uh
the us clients
obviously a lot of people
uh from what i can see conversations i'm
having obviously you said that you did
contract to uk but maybe you could just
use a reference point of uk perm and
everyone
and your eu whatever but like what what
ended up being the sort of in and around
the percentages that you ended up
agreeing with these companies because a
lot of people are under the impression
they can be a lot more higher than than
the uk
uh is this for contracts in in the us
so obviously
you've been doing perm us right
yeah we we have a handful or we've made
a handful of contracts yeah no i was
just curious like because a lot of
people say ah the sort of terms you can
agree in the us is more like 25 30
sometimes even 35
whereas on perm whereas in the uk
typically you're hearing 15 18 20 20
like you get what i'm in so i don't know
you don't have to obviously give me your
exact like average percentage agreed but
like what did you find ended up being
like the percentages that you were
mainly talking to customers about
yeah between
25 35
is um
and then the and then how how have you
found like obviously again this can vary
from state to state and you can share
insight on this but
salaries as well again it's all relative
right in terms of cost of living these
things but salaries to the type of skill
set that i know is contract so it's not
quite the same but like how have you
found that has it been much more
salary wise in terms of the vacancies
that you've worked on compared to uk
yeah it's um it's fairly significant
although the caveat to that has been
we've been working in a um
higher cost of living areas is somewhere
focused because it pumps the salaries up
and also industry focus has typically
been
higher paying industries that said
like for like with with uk um roles we
definitely do see
an uplift for for the same kind of
positions
what how significant we talking
what would be like an example if is it
like i don't know 60k in the uk and it's
like 90k in the u i don't know i know
it's dollars to uk pounds but we're
talking roughly
so
some of the grads that we look at are on
like nine thousand dollars um we
positionally from the grads
yeah
um
yeah i know wild um so
double
that's interesting
okay so
what one of the questions i had online
which i think is an interesting one
which i think this is probably a
relevant time to ask it
is what have you said what have you
found to be like the main differences in
the recruitment process compared to
maybe the uk and i know obviously did
contract recruitment again but like from
what i'm sure you understand obviously
and but like what what would you say
have been the main differences if any
from a uk maybe typical recruitment
process compared to the us
so
companies in the us can be very um used
to the typical u.s staffing agency
generalist model
and obviously we're going in this from
from a different angle we're going niche
hyper focused on small skill sets
what we can find with with some
companies is because they're used to
that model they will just go after
sending vacancies in bulk
here john just go and fill these without
the the background
and
that makes a massive difference to
conversion to
whether we're actually going to have any
joy with the vacancies so it's so
important to set your stall out really
early on with with clients that we need
to do a thorough
process early doors
in order to really understand the usps
of the business the projects
why candidates should come and
take join these these businesses because
otherwise
you very very quickly lose candidates
through
processes if the proposition isn't
strong enough if you can't demonstrate
the value as to why they should stay in
this um in this process
so yeah that that was um quite
interesting
so yeah so what you're saying there
actually is
like hopefully good uk eu consultants
should be doing is like being
consultative
like not just being order takers right
so what you're saying there actually is
because a lot of these us-based
companies have been used to working with
generalist agencies
who say john here all our vacancies like
try and get some candidates for us
so they're they're order takers it's a
bit more transactional you're saying
what you had to really make sure you did
get that upfront investment on from the
client side is look we need to work
together here to
understand like where you're at i might
be able to offer you some insight on how
you match up against other companies
your process right now is is going to
put people off like those types of
conversations and as you said really
understanding
from that client perspective like what
is it what is their usb in the market
why would people be excited to work for
them what are the projects they're
excited about and do all of that upfront
work so has that been actually
quite receptive then when have people
gone
this is great that we're doing this
there's a lot of hiring managers
um with
pain in in these markets at the moment
that are struggling through those
avenues so
again it's it's an opportunity to
demonstrate your credibility that you're
taking the time out to to do this where
others aren't
but
it's also your opportunity to consult
and to educate on actually
appreciate you've utilized different
hiring processes before
this is a way that i know works and i i
will demonstrate that to you through
this process
in doing that we have been able to sort
of reduce um stages through processes
introduce more
remote stages to to it so that we can
get this turnaround
much faster
there is always that conversation around
um
uh
candidates in the u.s having two week
notice periods which is absolutely
correct but you can find if you allow it
um hiring processes can run for
significant periods and periods of time
the urgency needs to get built into that
quickly
yeah that's interesting that's a really
great insight that and then on on this
and then let's go into like how you've
gone about growing your team and all of
that exciting stuff
we i obviously i know you said that you
listened to part of it but when i sat
down with josh
to have a similar conversation he
mentioned that insight around like
contracts and making sure you you get
those contracts signed with clients
is there is there any other obviously
this isn't a law podcast by any means
and we're not offering law advice but
like any other like contractual things
that you've had to learn along the way
that have been quite instrumental or
important to understand if i'm looking
to go into the u.s market that yeah
would be good for us to take a bit of a
note here
yeah so josh's point about contracts
absolutely resonated with me you need to
get it signed before you work the
vacancies
but on that note our contracts are very
lengthy
and i'm very upfront with our clients
about that
it's about protecting both sides
because of this it can be a long
conversation around getting terms signed
and agreed so anyone going to market
needs to
be well aware
that
your first client it might be a couple
of months before you've actually got
those terms in place um certainly we
have had terms going through that have
taken two three months
in order to to get everyone on the same
page about what's fair and what protects
both sides
key points to to focus on are certainly
around guarantees and rebates um
candidate ownership
um but yeah it's um it can certainly be
a lengthy process
so
how how long like what did you where did
you want to get this this sort of desk
business to before you started to look
to
take people
underneath you and start growing the
team
i wanted five solid clients coming to me
consistently for the same skill set um
we managed to get to that
fairly quickly although it probably took
12 months
before
we were building
around 12 months to get to that point
yeah i mean i was billing consistently
i'm sure you were with more clients than
five and 12 months but as you said
it's the consistent consistently coming
to you part
with the same skill set yeah absolutely
no thank you for being honest with that
because i think that sort of shows that
i saw a post recently
where like someone who's done the
american market for a while
shared like um
[Music]
he's seeing stuff at the moment where he
feels like people portraying doing
recruitment in the u.s market is easy
obviously that's just not the case is it
that's not where we're not saying no not
one part of you said this has been easy
it's just talking it's just trying to
learn about the nuances and i think the
main thing i don't know if you agree
with this but i feel like the main
thing that people are drawn to
and it won't always be the case depends
on what market you focus on but like
john the uk eu recruiter can sort of do
all the things that we've spoken about
and
look for the same skill set and it's
hard to find
get these hard to find people
place them um but then the end reward of
the fee and the earning potential is is
just higher in the us
yeah it is and that seems like the nuts
and bolts of it is the this is still
just as hard
honestly the candidate attraction piece
and actually getting these people into
your processes i've found so much harder
um than the uk like
the us is a great place to recruit
absolutely i'm so excited about
the opportunity there and where we can
take things but i'm still like fully
believe in the uk recruitment market i
think there's there's great things going
on in germany as well like
it the us isn't going to solve all
problems it's not going to be something
that everyone can go out there and make
a success of immediately overnight
you've got to be very focused on
building relationships um generating
your networks and and really
focus on what you're doing i think if
you're going into this with a scatter
gunner approach i'm going to find a good
candidate in whatever niche it is
and um be a million-dollar biller
overnight i just don't think that's
realistic it's not going to happen yeah
no yeah thanks for being honest with
that so i was going to ask you around
the growth of the team and stuff and
we'll do that but just because you
shared it
let's talk about the challenges then so
you just mentioned there which is
around the candidate attraction piece
has that been one of the the challenges
then obviously you've been doing
placements and you've been growing the
team but what what specifically is have
you found it like a sort of challenge
um so
speaking to hiring managers as as i
alluded to before like
it's such a great feeling when you're
doing it in engineering contracts you've
got a beast cv you're running wild and
and speaking to everyone that's been a
big difference and that's been a real
challenge like getting through to these
people in
the old ways that it's like specking on
cvs
yeah it's backing but that hasn't been
working
if you're sending it to the right people
having the right conversations
um but it's making sure that you're not
going wild with it
spam just doesn't work
um but yeah having solid conversations
it takes time you've got to demonstrate
your credibility in one way or another
be it get your capability statements in
front of people engage through forums or
have like online conferences etc
um but yeah that's been difficult
candidate attraction
is is tough i mean maybe it's
different in in other niches
as i say we are super specific but that
has paid dividends on the other side of
things so
when you have got a solid candidate and
you really believe in them and we've got
like a grading structure on whether um
they are a good candidate for us
then you you can be a lot more confident
that you're going to go on and make a
placement
um
outside of that it's understanding sort
of the differences in the market so
um
getting your head around the benefits
packages the 401k the
healthcare and and how that works in the
us
that's certainly been a challenge and
that's been one of those where you just
have to or i've had to learn it as i
went um but now a whole framework around
that that we can talk with the team
about um so yeah it's
honestly like the last two years have
been great for that it's every day has
been a different learn there's there's
something like a new visa has has come
to me and like i've never heard of it
before so you go research that can our
clients yeah it's amazing again it's
being curious right
so
what what's been like what's been if you
were to look in the last two years
what's been the most sort of common way
that you've ended up the most common way
that you've um found a a candidate or
you've ended up getting a candidate
working with you and your
your team so has it been has it been
through headhunting has it been kind of
referrals
out of interest has it been linked in
emails well again we can talk about
holistically but what would you say has
been the main
well-targeted emails um candidate
referrals has has really been the one um
if you do a good job again we talked
about networking if you take
one of the biggest things that that i
talk about is set your stall out early
with clients with candidates this is
what i'm going to do
this is how i'm going to do it this is
where i'm going to speak again and
follow up on it make sure your process
is watertight and if you're
demonstrating that to candidates to
clients consistency consistently
referrals on both sides come
and you can build that into your process
yeah if you're deli yeah go yeah really
deliver on your service say what you're
gonna do
all those things
okay so obviously got to the got to the
year mark then which is when you really
started to sort of build people
underneath you
um what so what was again you don't have
to give me exact but i know people be
curious so i hope you don't mind me
asking what was like the first year goal
like billings wise
billings
300
pounds was your was your goal
yeah
what'd you manage today
uh my first full year was 450.
it's mega from a stand start
yeah it's decent you probably were you
proud of that was you like surprised by
it or yeah yeah i didn't i went into
this not knowing like where it was going
to go what was capable expectations
i'm sure you would have been obviously
confident with all the things that
you've learned and everything but that
that's that's amazing
again from the stand start
yeah um
so
what was what was the approach then when
it comes to hiring for your team then
john let's let's talk a bit about that
um
because i'm really interested
to find out like how you found hiring
people to the american hours but
um
in the uk
yeah absolutely so
we started
i started working u.s hours consistently
from from the very beginning
um and worked great for me
i'm a father of two young girls so i get
my time with my girls in the morning i
go to the gm i do all my life admin um
and and that works really well and
that's something that i try and talk to
people about a lot because
it's something that you don't
necessarily get in in the nine to five
the converse of that is it is different
to a normal recruiter's role right so
you can't just go for the after work
pints and
um in like meals with your team as
easily and things like that and
whilst it was fine for me doing it on my
own
that
was different when trying to
attract and retain people so we're fully
flexible now
we talk about work your
work your day so
how
work the hours that that you need to in
order to to make sure your business
moves forward each day that might be
working you at uk hours one day
work until midnight another it's all
dependent on
on what you've got going on in the
business
outside of that we started working u.s
bank holidays we're now in uk again to
help with the retention and attraction
but really recruiting for the team it
was about demonstrating the vision that
we've got for the us where we're taking
things how
far we've come so far the backing we've
got from from the vantage business
and showing that to um to people joining
the joining the journey with us and
the
flexibility
the the way we're we're taking this has
has been a really successful win for us
and we've got a great group of um
people in the team to um to take the
business forward
so john as as you were saying it seems
like you've been on a bit of a journey
when it comes to
getting the internal
sort of proper proposition right for
someone joining your team who works the
american hours
so you're saying something you've had to
work out is obviously
the like flexibility you said something
around
like um i can't remember how you worded
it but like getting the work done rather
than like how many hours worked or
something
yeah is that right i don't know what you
how you worded it
uh work your day work your day yeah like
that work your day so what you're saying
like that is like hold yourself
accountable this is about the outcomes
not about john checking how how long he
was on bullhorn for
yeah exactly so
um i mean we have the same sort of hours
in in a week in in the office as is any
normal or from home as any normal
recruitment concern but the way we look
at it is flex in that so if you've got a
really admin heavy day or you have
even you want to go out for tea in the
evening then bring your day into uk
hours and make sure that works for your
business
likewise
you're often going to have calls with
candidates late in the evening so start
later work work work later and and just
make it work for your business
and what's ended up being again i know
everyone's individual but i think this
would be interesting what what's ended
up being like the typical working week
for someone that obviously works for
works for you and your team but does
works the us market what might a typical
week look like or like the typical day
look like
hours wise
yeah just like what the typical working
day might look like do i am i starting
at 11 and i'm working until 8 pm like i
don't know what does it end up looking
like
well there's a real mix in the in the
team like there's a
couple that really like working late
having having a sort of
line in the morning things like that so
um the work they do tends to be sort of
one till 10 um i'm often working 11 8.
um we generally have a bit more of a
compact down on friday anyway um just so
that we we have a bit more of the
weekend and we're not working through to
midnight obviously if there's work that
needs to be done then natural
recruitment we get it done but
yeah it's um it's variable across the
team and that's the great thing we we
offer that flexibility
work from home when you need to or you
want to i know a lot of people like
being in the office we've got a great
environment but there's no expectation
on on anyone to be here all of the time
how how was that then showed up in you
managing these people because that must
be quite hard because like
you'd like to think it'd be a bit easier
for everyone you know when you're seeing
your team you're working the same hours
you know what i mean how have you
approached that
we have a shared calendar it works
really well like
they can see the hours that i'm going to
be in the office i can see everyone
else's we tend to make it work pretty
seamlessly it's um
i had the same concern early on when we
were talking about how we can make this
flexibility work how we can make it work
for everyone actually it just does like
as i say you put the calendar together
everyone's
sort of responsible you you it's on your
own back like if you want to be in here
and be part of the um the office then
absolutely come in
otherwise
everyone's used to teams everyone's used
to sort of engaging with each other on
the phone and having those conversations
so it's it's nothing major now
and you're saying the other sort of real
important part has been like the vision
of like what that could be part of what
it could be in the future because when i
have sat down with sat down with a chat
called um patrick who's building like a
yeah a us
um recruitment business but from the uk
and then taking people over and he said
that again everyone's individual like
you've got a family right so you may not
be motivated by this but he sort of
found that like
i don't call it like a carrot but like
the end goal being that we can help you
take your career to the states is
something that really excites a certain
certain type of people
so don't if that's something that a
story that you're also telling people is
like look this is where we are today
however absolutely there's going to be
an opportunity to take what we've built
here work really hard for to then take
your life over there is that something
you thought about
that's absolutely something we've
thought about and it's part of the
business plan we're opening an office in
the u.s in april next year light in the
sand is there we're working towards it
um so
absolutely there will be consultants
within the business that are going out
there'll be people that join our company
that
will have the opportunity to relocate to
the us
equally germany equally the other areas
yeah the other places yeah but if you
found that's like the for the right type
of person or a certain type of people
that's got that's like have you seen
their eyes light up and that's something
that
they think about maybe is one of their
bigger goals
yeah absolutely i mean it's
what a cool way to to go and um
experience your recruitment career in a
different country
i'm very settled where i am i'm very
happy in like my status in the uk but
um i know it's it's a driver for a lot
of people to be able to go and
experience
different areas of the world and
certainly there are people in the team
that that is a driver for
so obviously i'm assuming then what have
you again this isn't a law podcast
but like what have you had to make sure
you have set up so like you just said
looking to get an actual office there in
april of i'm assuming that the companies
supported you and got things like
setting up like a legal entity in the
u.s is something that you had to get
done before
yeah
yeah that's
that's mostly not being my side of it
yeah of course about the vision about
that well you don't have to have an
office there do you
no no you absolutely don't and and we're
very clear with with everyone that this
business is being built on both sides of
the ponds um it's not that yeah that's a
good point the us division and you're
going out there one way or another this
is about
look we can do it we can make it work
either way um and
that's that's also really important
yeah so look i've got i've got a couple
of like final questions that people sort
of shared on linkedin and stuff but
before before i sort of hit you with
some of those and we sort of wrapped
this up
i guess like firstly what what you're
excited about mate i think you've you've
worked you've clearly wear your absolute
socks off
uh you've obviously yeah built this team
now i can sort of sense how how excited
you are like what what's um where would
you like to to see
this business and this us team that
you've been building in another sort of
12 24 months
so the end of this year we'll be at nine
consultants by summer august
next year we're looking to take that to
18
and we've got a real vision in place for
2025 being four separate brands within
the us um as per our uk business
i'm really excited to drive that like
there's
so one of my favorite things that i've
ever done in recruitment is build
patches build businesses and and help
develop people that are doing that and
that's really where i i want to see
us grow in and and
being a big part of that
and i guess for you as well it must be
really cool
to sort of get exposed to like maybe a
bit more like business strategy how
we're going to approach this all those
types of things as well
yeah absolutely
it's
i've i've always
had an entrepreneurial streak and it's
great being out i love recruitment for
that you can use it in so many different
ways
um and being able to look at the
strategic side and where we're taking
things next over the next 12 24
10 years um yeah it's exciting that's
amazing so let me let me just hit you
with maybe like just one or two
questions if i may and then we'll we'll
wrap it up there if that's all right
absolutely
so the first one that i had this came up
a couple of times and i think you sort
of mentioned this maybe loosely at the
beginning so i wanted to ask it was that
the question is um
which product retained solutions have
been most successful
how have you gone about improving your
contingent relationships i know that
sort of two questions but
um so how have we gone about improving
our contingent relationships
certainly based around um
regular meetings in the diary
consistently both parties are
involved in it and there's buy-in from
the client side as to why there is real
merit in that that's had a huge impact
on relationship building on process and
how we move
uh well what do you sorry it's about
what would you sorry to buy in but what
do you call those meetings
just by weekly movies what's the purpose
sorry like what's the like what's the
purpose like why why is a client going
to go john yeah happy to give you
45 minutes of my time every couple of
weeks because these people going to be
time poor no doubt
yeah absolutely but they're also really
crying out for the talent that that
we've got it's the opportunity for both
of us to have a serious conversation
about what's going on the market who's
hiring who's taking your staff
where where your attrition might be
coming from but also it's our
opportunity to really delve into the
progress reports that we talk to our
clients about and
why
why are you sourcing this talent where
are you missing the mark who who is
getting these talent instead of you and
what can we do about it it's an
opportunity to have that strategic
conversation about the hiring and really
partner with that process
that's brilliant i love all those things
that you just said what what yeah that's
the i think that's brilliant so what
what what sort of type of um products
and solutions have you about have you
found be more successful are you at the
moment mainly working with your
customers on a retained basis
exclusive
how's that played out
yeah exclusive that's working really
well not so much on the retained side um
we do run mini msps for projects with
with clients that's been very effective
um
but yeah
okay i've got another i've got and i'll
ask you one more question but i just
wanted to this is to what you just said
but i just i'm curious
what do you
how like if i was to say to you john
what are the principles to consistently
gaining exclusivity with my clients
what what would you say
it might be some of the things you're
talking about today but what would you
say yeah for
for me it's been the capability
statements and particularly the client
referrals
you get a quiet referral and that's
massive internal to a new hiring manager
external to a partner business a sister
company
um that's really led to strong exclusive
relationships
love it so final question this came from
someone but i think it's a nice question
to end on what has surprised you most
about this us journey so far this u.s
market having come from obviously the
background that um you've come from uk
europe
how different every day is
like
i know it's always always the same in
recruitment
how much i'm enjoying it still after two
years of building um and
the opportunity that there is
if you're doing things right if you're
taking a niche approach the way that you
can
engage with global brands
i never found that opportunity in in the
uk um to to
get in with some of the the biggest
brands in the industry
effectively and quickly
um and that's that's something that i've
been really surprised with if you're
doing it right doing the the full
process right
love it john's been absolute pleasure
excited to see where you're on another
two years
thank you so much for
sharing like you you've um yeah you've
shared a lot today so i just want to say
thank you for that i know this would be
really helpful for so many people what
an exciting time to be part of your
journey and yeah i know you have big
growth plans and all those things so
yeah look john thank you so much for
joining me it's been a real pleasure
yeah absolutely thanks for having me